you can get your ass in here my dad
asked for the face ready
haha Wow once upon a time in an Old
English country of Scottsdale Arizona it
was a man who dreamed dreams to taste
the previously made invention of
pancakes and turn it into something
incredibly new interested in fantasy he
made Mickey Mouse was willing to be
embedded for another 400 years into a
pancake shape and with that and created
a new era of pancake consumption which
was a time-honored tradition among the
pagans Eastern Europe so from then on an
desired that it was time for us to
revive this lost art of pancake art that
I can't do it alone anymore friends or
whatever is nearest and will do
substitute friends
Tyler the apocalypse
shine known for his devastating flippin
capabilities if you were to flip it on
its head faculty you would annihilate
the entire universe of untold
destruction
he's build one to flip so hard it
cracked the very crust of the ocean
causing untold destruction
you remember Noah's Flood what colors
discs and although even the crop master
if you order eaten question anybody who
has the greatest crispy golden this club
in the world
and even there is no telling that how
good that crust can be context of the
pancake resided might be bad the crust
the flaky but appearance the crispy
cannot be being on any scale and you may
be wondering who I am among these
Tyson's appendage well I can't believe
you don't recognize me maybe not with
this face it's me markiplier mark mark
mark mr. butterworth
Trish Bach
oh yes that's true if you were wondering
what makes beer so thick and juicy
there's a hundred percent me baby from
you know why there's a national
recycling program for these because they
send it to Maya for Sophie covering
every single pancake out there in
existence 100% me so let's get started
with this trio of perfection how can
things go wrong only power each other in
Mortal Kombat's yes each in our own
right legendary among the pancakes
profession Otto's but we are here to
bring this home to another level
pancakes we're going to take your
injection and your suggestion going to
make the greatest best phantasticus
mystically pancakes in existence and who
so ever makes it and whom so ever makes
the greatest best most accurate pancake
to your desires win so let's get started
shall we shall we shall we shall we
shall we're going in raw undirected
we're not using recipes we're not using
measuring cups we've been doing it for
thousands of years we know exactly what
to do with these ingredients to make the
best pancake possible and you may be
wondering up Witherspoon Beecham spoon
little thanks ooh
bake them a spoon boom Oh will you but
you'll have to
minutes to make of that matter that we
can know buttermilk here unfortunately
some I know is wanting me to make fun of
the pancakes at all I made oh wait I
look kind of down three two one yeah
usually as my dad would have done this
he would have put this in the fridge
overnight now you know two fully mixed
and you know rise a bit but good a
little bit you know off the off the farm
to end well
more like the incredulous shy wool
disorder oil in your pit their finest
bonded
I got oil it hit birthday did all right
so as you can see my opponent here
unintelligibly went for two eggs when
obviously you should only use one and
you don't want to you want you don't
want to gluey a pancake the more protein
you have in there the more it's gonna
stick you want to floppy answers that go
light on the mix Marv are set to low and
oh [ __ ]
gob stop those are my settings house
it's time you have a minute NZ we got
this chop-chop shot we used to make
pancakes in our sleep so you may be
wondering how this doesn't seem so bad
oh we're going to be judged on taste
composition and accuracy to the prompt
that's how we're going to be judged then
think about it no one thinks it's not at
all you can't taste my batter on a boat
you can't take my batter on No
too much cue that a good squeeze shooter
I think I make a most bathroom yes by
part it's the very it's about to be in
quality over quantity
well you need problem comes it yeah just
like with YouTube it comes about
quantity of videos about quality that's
remarkable okay do we get to wash your
hands are never visible to their
professor back in your bowl [ __ ] then
it doesn't take till Christmas honey
please I don't know Tyler needs big
European pencils because you know
conservative go flow ocean buff the
shuriken four thousand you white Oh
Michael wife a big boy becomes it with
exactly my business Joe we've also got
food colouring for us
stupidity don't know why that there
where have that idea
no not you Oh spray down go to the brick
spray yourself [ __ ]
should I try really good friend Fred you
are the crust after all
well this is what he's a master it ain't
come there's no but this is why he's the
master if you question the master you
can fit in the ass
there's the deal if you like isn't it
yes ask a lot of questions if you don't
all right so what we need is we need
your suggestions right now write in the
comments right now no we have to color
search home other words I'm not coloring
until it gets on the grill mm-hmm
where's my back give me a here's your
face thank you leave your affection
that's Tyler's face don't touch don't
touch my yoga [ __ ]
touch it are you up for business level
oh oh all right its back on
we've got our 3d we've got some squid
we're into we go free dude I let someone
sleep better a squeeze myself back in
the eighteen twenty-four were 13 people
in the small town of Salem Oregon they
thought someone with wish because they
made a pancake are just in the exact
representation of Satan himself
yeah sizzling participation they they
have Commission to the local link this
and but as soon as she touched the water
suddenly and talked about in turn this
Europe and this is how those most famous
which is all because
butter or earnest economy though we're
all here
the yellow not good story that was a
vacuum filing white pocket boys
runny hurt me Harley by whom into
forests in him sick bummed away Anjali
[Music]
well the sub could really help turn
under what turns to go a dog look like
[ __ ] dog
she did not look like a [ __ ] dog we
mean if i watch the frickin is very much
like a [ __ ] dog if I'm not if I'm fun
to be mistaken here mine is corrupted
come on is corrupted someone else to
changes my body
Oh girls not there we go let's go with
executed perfectly
you took encourage how can I live up
your name only dream nightmares
my god you become the Crypt hey what is
that what is that who I'm lit No
No as you can see Kirby you actually
decent Kirby's a surprisingly good hurry
pervy the Cowardly Dog so as you can see
courage courage
Kirby's pretty good not so mad I'm still
there wah wah wah wah low judge this
later that the initial first look we're
going to fill out our plate with
multiple things there's going to be a
good choice with Tyler the apocalypse
shine he knows that Kirby's the most
destructive force known to man and in
all the new game world there is no one
more sinister and more devastated than
curry
all right whatever new predictions
flavor we had heard that's a really good
fit or look thanks we'll see I'll change
my if I can put it this thing I may need
to borrow spatulas is my stuff is not
coming out of the freaking bottle whoa
careful don't go on top of mine oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] mark [ __ ] sorry son sorry
I've ruined yours
[Music]
in an omelet wait are you home I am
literally ahead oh yeah you're just
better that's your main problem your
batter is off so consistent I had a hard
time because my my stuff isn't coming
out right no oh yeah these people run
please exhibition my are consistent and
so are yours and mine or Squidward's
encourage the guard with off mmm yes all
right
so uh yeah that was pretty good last one
I had no idea how to draw Squidward I'm
bad from memory or whether it be last
part I'll do over okay peaceful relaxed
good change from our normal for Higgins
and things that we do I just wanted to
kind of say that I really love making
videos because like it kitchen some of
the greatest joys in my week to be able
to come together and watch you fail and
you succeed but in the wrong way
territory using your finger to draw it's
really inspiring you know you may fail
but you fail it in a wonderful way thank
you really should that make you that
look amazing thank you one of the one of
the most cherished times when I was
brought up with them my dad made
pancakes
rekindle Sunday and he loved he he was
like a cherished tradition of ours every
Sunday morning we'd have pancakes and he
would start preparing on Saturday
because he would have them sitting
overnight via India in the fridge you
know just kind of like cooking and
getting ready when they were just the
best pancakes I've never had any other
pancake from any other place that was
nearly as good as my definitely Ethan's
my uh pretty good my first attempt to
make an RNA I've never made kind of
cater to tourists I like oh you didn't
use any color yes I do I mean that sound
like you just don't think a Korean
uneasily you have to use the amount of
cook well that's not bad I can
definitely see it take out my issue was
the batter's eye yeah your battle with
[ __ ] well it was I was trying to fill it
in yeah it's hard when I don't have the
squeeze suppose I think you had the
right amount of like baking soda because
you're the sticker
I'm under this pin probably the chewy
but here's our service across town
here's boom so it comes down to this
there's three categories of judgment
number one quality of the pancake
yourself outside of art out of the taste
is it close to a pancake number two how
close is the art to the actual thing
that it was supposed to be like if it
encouraged homer and Squidward where
they can eat actual inspiration and
number three taste how does it taste
which tastes the best bar none what
taste of us okay makes sense
and that's how we're gonna heat it but
we have impartial
ah who's tasting the pinhead we know we
know there are three pancakes one for
each of us we trade out which one is you
can have courage I'll take your courage
you can have square things reason you
trade in my third word time in Auburn
oh sorry not know this one and now this
worked out so Mimi's got one of these
will further with artistic
interpretation like which one do you
guys think was closest to the heart mark
this is courage we're starting with her
starting encourage her I'm voting I'm
voting Marcus based upon the place yeah
I really wish I could be courage out of
this one but I just occurred in oh this
is women I was a likely putting words in
the middle of a pink bullet
no I gotta give it to myself to for
Squidward obviously it's between mark
and me and Mark is definitely the land I
don't know about that god I got this
bill Homer Simpson I actually got to
give a little credit for this one I
could see homework because what I was
trying to do is out few were doing the
same thing I'm trying to make that mouth
is brown and I'll try to make that
different I can see the mouse distinctly
better it just seems like a rest of it
Khalil I like I ov er float it in the
end all places freezin yeah I'm gonna
get 3d I write ya mouth not
the drinking problem like um you need to
get down to the hair on here and I gotta
give you props for that
okay I didn't know if that would turn
off I think I think overall mark wins
artistic thing 100%
so by textures and I think we'll just go
over all because it was just a batter
the batter check I gotta give it the
Tyler because this is more like yeah it
looks more like a pancake minor very
thin his pancake like mine are very why
again we got a like location this
reminds me of like crepe grapes then
this is extra ad this one like the
crispy medically under here the cross
it's even the security area will see me
I would give it a charger for the
pancake mastitis angry he's got the
batter down yeah now you're coming to
the card for me okay alright we have to
try it with house throw up and then with
okay well we're just going to go through
each person I think that we should go
blind
we only know all right babies in bar
cheers Cheers Twinkies first week as
firstly it's very sweet I do appreciate
it this white is fluffy it is what we
play it's not bad that nice crystal is
not about it's just weird cooling in the
middle of goofy smile enough you just
have to say I just pick one yet but that
isn't I don't mind I do know how to
discipline is not bad not fan cake I
would I would end it tomorrow
alright let's try this here is a little
bit bland bullwhip definitely little
without like pancakes
tasting this is my texture this is the
one that could use Europe what you can
have we want to those
a strap-on mm-hmm okay okay not bad
pancake not a sweet which may or may not
be good but in my mind I feel like even
better all right we've got a little
sweet little bland will pilot beer
anything so will Chewie - I would say
just a little chewy it's got good flavor
nobody up it's sweeter than mine Julie
but it's looking this walk quite enough
yeah I thought it was going to be for
your speed wait is it turned up thicker
and it's not bad but weirdly enough I
got yours easy
I don't do it tastes good it looks bad
it tastes good okay yeah that's a point
for everybody now your problem we all
win we're all winners
I already my pants are like how do you
mind are you I mean I just like it was
all that sugar that funded it oh yeah oh
that's super glasses are your office
yeah I think we all are the winners in
our own way I have the artistic
interpretation you have the pancake you
look and feel of it and USA still room I
like it that worked out really well I
mean not every competition has to end in
bloodshed and terror no I will never
step in with a special thank you for
that oh can be so much to me so anyway
that is the end of the pancake challenge
we hope you guys enjoyed this we have a
lot of fun making it we had a lot of fun
doing this and from eating the crust
Nestor - Tyler via apocalypse the twelve
apocalypsis Charlie and me mark mr.
butterworth Fishbach and I expect
excellence it was a fighter
I just want to make pancakes oh yeah I
cart we would love to see it send it to
us [ __ ] Instagram Twitter mr. butter
put it in the comment yes sir just let
us know if you guys want to do is really
easy to do users could squeeze well
severe kick mix-ins just climb it up so
get away thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always we will see you
internet video bye